Ah, that new Greek
tanning place?
'Santorini tan'
is doing, uh, half-off
for law enforcement.
You get half off
of any tanning
or, uh... What they call
speed tanning.
I have an announcement
to make!
Suck my big black [bleep]!
I won to [bleep] lotto!
I won the [bleep] lotto!
I am a [bleep]
millionaire!
And I don't have to
[bleep] sit here anymore
and listen to your bull[bleep]
you [bleep] crazy [bleep]!
[bleep] you!
[bleep] you! [bleep] you!
Suck my [bleep]
you mother[bleep]
[bleep]sucker!
Argh!
'Yes!'
[mouthing words]
"03-06-14-18-46-51."
Okay, that was a misprint.
Okay.
Everybody had that.
Apparently they printed
uh, thousands,
thousands of them.
- 'Everybody--'
- Yeah, that ha... It happens.
Put suck your [bleep]
on my to-do list for me.
Uh, when I said that
out loud, it was, um--
Oh, I'm so sorry
not everybody's here.
'Cause what I want to say
I wanted to say
to all of you butt bloats
all at once...
- 'Alright?'
- 'Um-hmm.'
You people have been
blisters on my taint
and not just blisters,
but in-grown hairs.
And yes, there's cabernet
in this cup, alright?
I won the lottery
last night.
You know why?
'Cause I willed it to happen.
'Huh?'
I'm gonna go out
and snort coke
off a black man's behind.
Uh, you didn't hear
about this?
"3-6-14-18-46-51"?
- 'Yes.'
- 'Yeah.'
(Jim)
'They printed 3000 of them.'
But, um, there is some
coke in evidence
and Jones is
a pretty good sport.
Nice coat.
Is it real?
You don't have to...
Don't...
Aw...yeah, baby!
[laughs]
Oh, suck it!
Suck it!
'Guess who won
the lotto? Guess!'
[laughs]
[bleep] you, mother[bleep].
[bleep] you!
For the record, you're
the second person to come in
and tell us to suck
your black [bleep].
(Jones)
'Who else did?'
[clicks tongue]